this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday august 1st it's a new month and a
whole new [__] week the joint
is brought to you by liquid iv listen i
do a lot of things to help clear my mind
and give me energy i do a little breath
work a little acupuncture i go to the
gym but the summer months are here and
we need to be proactive about keeping
our bodies fueled and hydrated making
hydration a priority can help us feel
healthier in our everyday lives now
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster than
water alone liquid iv is tremendous it
also comes in a hydration immune and
they also have a kombucha liquid iv
offers 10 flavors that are tremendous
pina colada tropical
punch cherry concord grape i love the
guava
berry tremendous you can use liquid iv
the first thing in the morning before a
workout or when you feel run down after
a long night out you know what i'm
talking about the single use package
makes it easy to stay hydrated while
you're traveling it contains five
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c get
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks now this i'm
going to take care you could grab liquid
iv in bulk nationwide at costco
but i'm going to give you 15 percent off
when you go to liquidity.com you
understand i'm going to give you 15 off
this stuff is expensive uncle joey on a
monday is showing up with 15 off so go
to check out use code joey uncle joey's
gonna give you 15 off and to joey at
liquid iv.com
you will not be sorry let's get this
party started
it's monday morning jack we're slinging
dick and giving out bubble gum
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
uh
ain't nothing free but jesus you bad
[__] it's monday august the
[__] first jack we did it through
another month this [__] year
is speeding right along [__] kovitz
making a comeback
uh my [__] mercy's godfather's got it
again i just heard from some girl that
had to cancel a trip she's got a bad
[__] code it didn't even sound like
you're on the phone but who gives a [__]
it's monday to rent this do you bad
[__] uncle joey slinging dick
with three hands not giving a [__]
[__] did some shows last week and
went down to uncle vinnie's did
wednesday night with don jameson and uh
[__] cuomo and
jimmy and eric man the [__] uncle
vinnie's is great on wednesday nights
then thursday i stuck to my [__] plan
of thursdays
and i went down to ashbury park [__]
beautiful i hadn't been in asbury park
in 40 years it looks like this [__]
clean nice city
uh
one of the guys from [__] uh
the green room
dispensary said hello my man charlie
choo choo charlie gave me some edibles
i'll tell you what guys i love listen i
i i live on abx edibles
but as anything else in life your
[__] tolerance
is key you know like i
wha what will kill most people with abx
like i eat 16 i open up with 1600
milligrams
and then i eat so much abx i got
diarrhea i get explosive [__]
diarrhea that smells like thc it's
tremendous
but from time to time people give me
[__] or i go buy like delta eights like
cbd lion delta eights got some [__]
kick to them but i built my tolerance up
to them i ate a whole [__] case of
those [__] but thursday night i
went down to asbury park my man choo
choo charlie came up to me
i gave him a bag of [__] uh
of uh wasn't tremendous it was rainbow
rap rub whatever the [__] it is
rainbow rutz and then uh
i was driving home and i'm like you know
what i'm almost like eight miles from
the house let me start eating these
[__] things
these little cherry edibles were so
[__] good i ate the whole jar on the
18 when i stuck my hand in the last one
i go wow
i ate the whole jar these [__]
then i got home and he had some
chocolate covered peanut butter cups
that were like delta eight and [__]
something else in there and i just
started inhaling those while i was
watching the yankee game and guys
when i went to bed at midnight my
[__] eyes
you could just see a pupil everything
else was red it was like the cover of
[__] uh
the rainbow rush the the one bag that
has my eyeballs all red like that so i
couldn't even make eye contact with my
wife i was so [__] embarrassed that's
how embarrassed i was
[__] liquid iv i'm drinking the guava
whatever the [__] it is guava berry
tremendous you understand me one [__]
bag 16 ounces of water your bran [__]
knew you put a little cell food in that
[__] which is a little oxygen
for your [__] cells your dick starts
getting hard ons from nowhere plus let
me tell you what you do you make a
protein shake like last night i did the
edibles
right friday night friday night i did
the [__] 1600 i i like all week i'd
live on different things to sleep
this week i did the cbd lion tincture
that [__] puts me the [__] out i did
that to like wednesday then wednesday
night i drank a [__] half a bottle of
[__] uh
what do you call that [__]
uh
nyquil without the nyquil
right the cherry flavored that lasted me
three nights but i didn't want to do it
three nights in a row so i said [__] it
let me do the edibles tonight so i did
1600 milligrams of edibles but it went
down with a particular liquid iv and you
ready for this
sell food it's got oxygen so let me tell
you something the [__] liquid iv the
edibles and the oxygen goes into your
stomach you start blowing these
two-minute farts
that are so [__] tremendous they
don't smell they just make a loud noise
and people look around
that's how good liquid [__] iv is so
anyway
so i [__] get home that night i'm
watching tv i go upstairs i gotta put
[__] cream on my face and [__]
and my eyeballs are beat the [__] red i
got up at 9 30 in the morning
friday morning you know i don't sleep
past eight o'clock 9 30 my wife woke me
up you're gonna get up to that one day
god damn i'm [__] high
but anyway i'll make them want to make
an announcement real quick guys i put
those tickets on sale last week i put a
code out wednesday thursday and they
went to general sale on friday i don't
know what's going on with the vip
tickets i fought and worked very hard to
do a residency in new york city and to
keep the prices low to 40 bucks
they said they'd have to hit you with a
service charger 10 bucks [__] it it's
new york city that's 50 bucks a ticket i
kept it low do me a favor guys and and
you heard it here
do not pay over
forty dollars for your [__] ticket
they got tickets on there now for 160
that people bought and the reselling do
not be a part of that guys please do not
be a part of it i'm gonna add more shows
i'm to be doing other shows in the bronx
brooklyn
nyack whatever the [__] do not pay over
40 hours for those tickets i leave those
tickets for you guys for 40 [__]
dollars it's monday and i'm telling you
this for the last time don't come to one
of my shows and when i'm talking to you
go joey i paid 160 a ticket and i'm
gonna go you pay 320 to come see me
you're a dumb [__] and i probably won't
[__] talk to you and insult you
because i've said it on numerous
stay with face value do not pay over
that it's sony hall.com that's it don't
go to any other [__] webpage
okay i'm hearing too much of this my
friends are going uncle vinnie's the
tickets are 20 15
some lady walked in there two weeks ago
and said she paid 132 a ticket
because what they're doing is they're
having you go to the name of the joint
it's uncle vinnie's comedy club let's
see you don't have to be a [__]
psychic to know it's gotta be uncle
vinnie's comedyclub.net
or uncle vinnie'scomedyclub.com
unless he's a [__] major league it
may be uncle vinnie's at gmail but
pretty much it's uncle any [__]
business you look into whether it's
jetblue.com
[__] whatever it's just add the [__]
you don't need to go to tickets r us or
vivid or any of that [__] to overpay
like a [__] [__] i'm doing this for
you i'm sorry i'm going off on you
because i'm sick of hearing this
this is are you people [__] stupid
you're going to the stress factory why
are you going
unlimitedtickets.com you're going to the
stress factory where is he playing
it's either calm or neck take a [__]
pick
after that if you go to the street if
you type in the stress factory okay
don't press the link
that says tickets to the left factory
are you stupid
there's a box on the right hand side
that says
stressfactory.com right under it with
the hours of operation you know the
[__] reviews from geniuses
that's the website
you don't go to where it says tickets
for uncle vinnie's or tickets for
madison square garden or tickets for
[__] the nassau coliseum or tickets
for the brooklyn you don't go on there
you go on the site of the [__] venue
hello
hello what the [__]
how are you paying 132 dollars a ticket
for a ticket to see me when the tickets
are 20 [__] dollars you know what
that makes me feel like like you're a
dumb [__] you're not listening or maybe
i didn't say it well enough it's sony
hall.com
that's it i'm trying to save you money
and for you not to feel like a [__]
mooc when you understand online and go i
think 182 and people like
look at this [__] idiot so please and
that's
across the board for everything
last week yankee tickets for against the
mets
were
593 dollars on the yankee website
my friends and i can't get tickets eight
hundred dollars what ticket
my friend's going tonight i got a ticket
for 333 from yankees.com
why did you go to vivid or where the
[__] you guys are going for tickets i've
never
seen this stupidity in all my [__]
life i'm here to save you money if i
want to rape you guys i'll charge you 89
a ticket i'm not worth 89 i'm telling
you this right to your [__] face so
knock at the [__] off and these prices
you [__] are paying for
concerts that now you've knocked america
out of going to concerts
like somebody told me what they're
paying for rage against a machine
they know what they're doing right it's
324 a [__] concert
buy blocks they buy the blocks
yeah they do it for everybody they buy
the blocks and then you guys are [__]
[Music]
so do not pay that people please i'd
rather the place be empty
then you pay 160 a ticket okay then they
have this thing direct ticketing
which they came at me before the
pandemic like they were an agency came
at me and said leave your agency we deal
with dynamic financing which means
we could get you like 300 for your
tickets after they go on set we do this
to everybody and i'm like what
and they're like yeah we buy the tickets
and then we sell them for the price of
that ticket on that day
that's what people were complaining
about with bruce springsteen
that his tickets were dynamic
ticketing
i love to explain it to you guys you
know you guys know i'm no [__] mental
genius
but when you log on to these ticket
sites it'll say ticket prices fluctuate
and change and price is some spiel
and you have to click okay to that and
that means that
you know
eight days out they're going to hold on
to that ticket and they're gonna keep
going up and down they're gonna look at
you uh
i'm sorry guys they're gonna look at
your cookies
or whatever the [__] on your computer
and see if you're a [__] that actually
pays for 400 tickets i mean that's they
just go by algorithms they know this
guy's a [__] felony stupid he's not
even misdemeanor stupid he's felony
[__] stupid
so we're gonna [__] double wham him
it's like when you go online for a plane
ticket you go to your computer at work
and you look for the price or you pay
plane ticket but you pay for your plane
ticket at home
because once you lock in that price on
your computer the algorithms of that
plane ticket we're going to stay on that
computer the prices are never going to
drop as a matter of fact they're going
to go up from the time you looked at it
it's a no-brainer
when you go home that night you look at
that same computer you've never looked
up that ticket on your computer you're
gonna get a way better price than you
have on your work computer
and a way better price than you got the
first day you looked at that [__]
ticket
that's why i want you to look at your
plane ticket at work or at your [__]
grandmother's house or at your [__]
father's house when you ready to buy the
[__] ticket you buy it at your house
this is why when you go on yahoo at work
and you look for joey diaz tickets
you turn your computer off you go to
[__] panera bread for lunch you come
back you go back on your [__]
computer and the first ad on your
computer is go see joey diaz in
cleveland and you're like cleveland why
you know it's it's tremendous how they
[__] you in the ass i'm just here to
help you out a little bit
a little [__] bit guys you got to
stop doing this [__]
listen there's a bunch of bands i want
to see there's a bunch of people i'd
love to see
i'm not paying 4 400 to go see bruce
springsteen i'm sorry
i'm not paying 326 dollars to go [__]
watch uh
tom morello jump up and down with the
other guys in the leg [__] cast i
just can't and i'm going to tell you why
the same reason i told my dear friend
steve avillo yesterday i'm gonna tell
you guys why okay plain and simple
not because i'm hip not because i'm
smarter than you and none like that i'm
gonna tell you why because i take pride
in what i did as a child
and i know for a fact
that whatever [__] country you go to
for the 324 hours i'm gonna drop this on
you
yesterday i was driving somewhere was
maybe thursday i was driving somewhere
and i heard comfortably numb
and sometimes on the radio you hear a
song and it sucks you in and it takes
you to that moment and sometimes you're
just thinking you're looking around
you see a harley [__] whatever
mustang whatever the [__] harley quinn
you know and but most of the time a good
song will suck you into where you were
at that point in your life
[__] comfortably numb sucked me in so
[__] hard the other day
that at one of the lights i had a
[__] um i had to go to i think i was
going to the health food shop
at the health food shop when i before i
went in there i stopped and i called my
friend steven villa who's his birthday
was on saturday last week happy birthday
my brother 40 [__] years
i called stephenville and he picked up
online to last spring i didn't even let
him say hello i go bills
i want to tell you something
the next time you get into an argument
with somebody about music or discussion
about music and they're telling you how
they i played eight hundred and
twenty-four dollars to go see elton john
he was magnus i said no he wasn't he's
just a chubby guy singing [__]
uh marilyn monroe songs now you don't
want to hear that nonsense with he looks
like [__] elvis went bad with the
belt on and i love elton john i [__]
went to tears the other night here and
don't let the sun come down on me
but i'm gonna tell you something guys
you could jump up and down pay your g
note for paul mccartney what do you
think about what i'm gonna say to you
right now
i paid fifteen dollars and fifty cents
to see david gilmour do the solo a
couple of vietnam on a wall on a hit of
acid
that's it
you could jump up and down all you want
and you've never [__] seen that so
i'm not paying 200 for anybody that ship
[__] sale and i don't expect you
[__]
to pay it for me if you guys want to pay
your [__] tickets for [__] high
ego people go knock yourself the [__]
out that's okay but you're gonna get the
same [__] thing from paying 15 and
going to an open mic it's the same thing
the nerves in your face are going to
crash together and it's going to bring
happiness to your world and that's what
you're seeking
but 300 bucks to be cool so you and your
friends could go to a concert with hats
on and take pictures
suck my [__] dick things are bad all
over you understand
i got a lot of great calls this week i
got a lot when i say calls nobody
[__] calls me i got a lot of great
emails this week about the ryan sickler
podcast
people were really like
joey we knew a lot of things about you
but we didn't know how love it overtaken
your life guys
in everybody's life at some point
there's got to be love there's got to be
a love overtake
you know i know that a lot of people
waiting for love i know people lived
their whole life and you know i just got
a [__] patreon email from some guy
him and his girlfriend broke up she
stole his money she was a degenerate
gambler listen you all need one of those
broads in your life
just to let you know that [__] you
know you got taken for your feelings you
know i'm saying like you we always need
somebody in our [__] lives to
to remind us that we ain't [__] you know
but i also
you can't live your life thinking that
after my divorce i was done you know i
have a dear friend
he's about my age and i always torture
him about
you know you don't want to die alone
you know and i mean that when i was a
kid i used to watch all those stupid
charles bronson movies and
clint eastwood movies and he was always
a guy that lived by himself every once
in a while he knocked some chick up on
the town they didn't see her again you
know
but i always thought how cool that was
until i got older as a man you know when
i was 28 i'm like i'm never [__]
getting married i'm never doing i was
22.
i was like i'm gonna be like charles
bronson have a studio apartment and
[__] live by myself maybe get a
goldfish
that's great when you're [__] 22. and
trust me that's great you know but as
you get older i know you don't like
women you don't want to be around them
they're stiffs they take up all your
energy
women are [__] bad i know i know i
know
but you can't live with them
and you can't live without
for a guy like me women have given me
everything
the strength i get in my daily life for
the last 40 years have been the strength
that i get from women i don't know why i
don't know why if you guys think i
gained my strength from watching pumping
iron with
arnold schwarzenegger and [__]
sometimes i really do i got a haircut
this week that was the best hour of my
week just watching girls cut hair
you know i get anxiety in this place
because some of the girls are 22
and they look [__] beautiful and
they're sweeter the [__] and i'm like my
daughter's barking up this tree 22 is
nothing my daughter's nine it's gonna be
ten and six [__] months 22 is right
around the corner trust me [__] trust
me
so you know i i get my strength from
women i always had you know and i had uh
listen when i was in the seventh grade i
got my first my first heartbreak you
know and uh
i got a little tougher after that you
know you get a little and then you start
acting like an [__] but then
when you're 13 you figure it out and you
start dating women and you know it's not
going to [__] last you hold hands you
swap spit spitting
you listen to donny osmond music
whatever the [__] you listen to
but i had never really had like a
childhood sweetheart so i always knew
that this was not gonna be you know i
got friends from high school that
married their high school sweethearts i
got 10 of those guys
in my world i'm really happy for them
that never happened for me but i i still
remember like in uh
i don't know like in 1990 something
maybe two early 2000
i was just listening to something and i
heard an interview with john bon jovi
and they asked him how
uh
you know how come his marriage has been
successful like most
rock stars lived like [__] animals
and and bon jovi
did something different with his life
and he answered that he got lucky the
first time you know he married his
childhood sweetheart
and everything worked out for him then
you have somebody like richie sambora
the guy right next to him his guitar
player who ended up marrying had a
locklear and they crashed cars and they
[__] snorted drugs and you know
and you and you look at that you go
listen man not everybody's perfect
i
had a relationship in 1984
that i was too young to comprehend like
she was a [__]
she was young too and she wanted to
[__] suck and i wanted to snort coke
so it was never going to work and then
in 85
i met a sweet young girl and we hit it
off and uh
i didn't know how to act i was still
buck wild and uh she tolerated me and we
lasted six years
i ended up going to prison and we had a
nasty breakup and it was a breakup that
you know i knew when i signed the
divorce paperwork and i started looking
at the demands i knew that i was gonna
lose my family like my daughter
i was gonna lose her and at the end of
the day i hate to say this
i don't hate her anymore but for years i
hated the person i had a child with
that's
that's a horrible [__] feeling you
know and she's not too [__] happy
about me so after that divorce that i
looked at my bank account get cleaned
out
and i looked at what a woman could do to
you and not every woman i was wrong at
the time i vowed just a
sling [__] dick you know for the rest
of my life i'm gonna be a dirty comic
you know there's nobody who wants to
marry me you know i had been
i'd been doing comedy like seven years
and i realized that listen guys
when you're a comic you it's like those
songs you hear
by bob seger on the road you know that
song he sings you know you meet these
women and you're there and you know you
listen to robert plant saying baby i'm
gonna leave you and all these songs when
you're becoming a stand-up comic and
you're like that's the life i'm gonna
lead you know like in your pathetic mind
lead i'm gonna be on the road and just
meet women and have to look at them in
the eye and go baby i'm gonna leave
someday and you hold and you listen to
[__] uh uh love hurts by nazareth
you hold each other and you get on the
bus and you know it's just a [__]
mind [__] it doesn't happen that way
guys or it didn't happen that way for me
so
i got separated in 1990 and for 10 years
guys i run a [__] iran
you know i ran
the way i wanted to run just having
casual relationship with women
doing drugs with them and moving on and
listen as
much as i didn't like casual sex
i didn't like it not only for myself i
didn't like it for what the woman might
feel like you know the next day you have
to see her and you you just did a 69 for
two hours and now you got to see her at
work or you know at the bakery the next
day and now you're not dating her and
one day you see it with a guy finally
and she introduces you like this is my
boyfriend chip and you're like
chippy if you only knew you should have
seen me a year ago putting fingers up
her [__] and all this [__] now she
wants you to meet chip and go to his
yoga class
you know i wasn't bolder with these
women so i didn't [__] know them all
they walk college girls and [__] like
that so you know this is what life is
guys and guys i was
from 80 [__] four to
from
[Music]
i think september of 84 october of 84
to august of 85. i didn't even see a
pubic hair on a woman
okay i don't have no reason a lot of you
guys and you know there was periods in
my life where i was single for [__]
long periods of [__] time
no girlfriend and not one that 10-year
stretch with no girlfriend and not
wanting one that that takes a different
type of [__] animal because you do
meet nice girls
you do meet nice girls but you know
as a man that i'm not going to do this
girl any good
why am i going to lie to her foreign
i'll be back and i'm not coming back
i'm getting 100 hours to come up here i
never want to come back you know what
i'm saying i just happened to meet you
and now you're nice and now i gotta move
on my way it's not gonna [__] work
you know how many times i was out with
girls doing coke and the girl was really
nice and i'm like i'm not even gonna
start swap and spit with her
and we would leave it at i'll call you
next time i come to town you know we'll
go out for coffee or whatever and then
you never talk to the person but at
least you don't have that guilt of
[__] sleeping with them never wanting
to contact them again maybe they had
acne maybe their feet smelled who the
[__] knows i'm no [__] specimen of
love either you know so
i had to be honest with myself so when i
talked to sickler
about that podca about that episode it
was about basically my wife and how
how if [__] the pieces fell together
regardless of what i wanted to do
like there was a time in my sometimes in
life
it doesn't give the universe don't give
a [__] what you got to do that's the
other thing about the universe if you
put your trust in the universe sometimes
the universe don't give a [__] about you
and what you think the universe is going
to give you what it thinks it's right
don't always count that you're witty or
i'm smart i knew how to decipher i knew
how to pick a good woman you knew
nothing you knew nothing i knew nothing
about picking a life partner i was 09
with [__] life partners i knew how to
pick girls to sleep with and
do 69 wouldn't snort cocaine with but i
didn't know how to meet a partner i
didn't know how to meet a woman to and i
didn't want to
see when you're not looking to meet a
partner you're going to meet scavengers
yeah you're going to meet people who
[__] they don't care about you either
they're looking for the same thing as
you
but sometimes the universe don't want
that
and i was very fortunate one day to walk
into the comedy store
and see my wife and
guys when i saw her like her blue eyes
just [__] it was you know the comedy
store is dark
it's a dark [__] place
so i was walking up the stairs when she
looked at me and i saw her blue eyes and
lit up that dark room
and again when i started talking to him
like here we go this is a nice girl
i can't do nothing with her
what am i gonna do with her
she don't do drugs she don't smoke pot
she's never gone to a [__] concert
like a crazy concert
you know she said that the craziest
thing that happened to her she went with
her girlfriends to chicago one time
and at the end of the night she lost her
girlfriends because they were all doing
heroin they lied to her and terry was in
chicago all along with four girls that
were on heroin nodding out and i'm like
that is the douchiest thing you could do
to a girl like terry because she doesn't
belong in that world
i knew as soon as my girlfriend my wife
told me she didn't get high go that's
gonna be a problem but it's not
it's not and when i started dating her
it was very like
i would push her away like terry this
ain't for you
like this this is not for you but she
kept on grinding me and asked me what i
wanted to do and then one day she cooked
me lunch guys and i was [__] blown
away
you know she made me like chicken with
red beans and rice and cornbread and i
was like
[__] a woman hasn't cooked for me
in a long time like women came over you
they did my drugs and they left in the
morning nobody ever asked if i was
hungry
nobody ever asked if i wanted to go to
breakfast this girl called me we hadn't
slept together or anything and she
called me she was like you want to come
over and eat lunch and i'm like yeah we
went over there we had lunch
we went we went and got coffee it was
[__] very like uh
not joey like it was had nothing to do
with what i had ever done before in a
girl
this is why i [__] uh walked around
with gloves on i didn't want to know
about my life i definitely didn't want
to know about the cocaine i definitely
you know i told her about the prison i
told her about all this [__] but i
didn't want i didn't want her to see a
negative side of me because i didn't
think she could handle it
like she was that sweet of a girl and
i'm like you know what
i'm gonna do what i do with all my other
relationships i'm gonna [__]
just do my best until one day she
decides i'm a loser and she'll disappear
on her own
there was only one problem she didn't
disappear
she kept showing up and we kept going on
for coffee and we kept going on dates
then we went to [__] a couple gigs
together and she started driving me to
gigs and then
came that one [__] time in july when
i was getting ready to leave and at the
time
i i'm not going to tell you guys that
when i first started dating my wife for
the first 90 days
what's happening you bad [__]
listen i want to talk to you about
better health you got to take care of
your mind you spend a lot of time taking
care of everything else your hair your
teeth you go to yoga and that's great
but your brain health affects how you
experience life investing time and
energy in mental health is crucial for
happiness eating right working out and
getting plenty of sleep but better help
makes online therapy accessible
convenient and affordable why is therapy
important let me explain something to
you i was struggling for a few months
and a friend told me to contact
uh
better help i did and today i'm living a
better life
i see my therapist dana twice a month
and better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy
sessions you're not gonna find a
face-to-face
therapist right now they're too high in
demand
the pandemic just worked my work worked
wonders on our minds but
better help is here for you you can
choose to see anyone on camera but it's
a lot more affordable than in person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist under 48 hours what i'm gonna
do for you the joint listeners get 10
off their first month
at betterhelp.com
slash diaz that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
diaz go over there right now
and talk to somebody live to help you
get through the rest of the year you're
going to need it better help
10 off when you put in code diaz so it's
betterhelp.com
diaz
now back to the show for the first 90
days
i didn't know what was going on you ever
get in the relationship you don't know
what's going on it's like i'm a chatty
type of dude are we dating now
so i didn't know what to do but i didn't
do nothing on this side either
you know what i'm saying
this is 2000. this is june
july august of 2000 her and i were
seeing each other a lot regularly
guys i don't have any reason why there
was no sex
i didn't want to treat this like i had
done all my other relationships
i didn't want sex to overtake everything
i wanted to really enjoy somebody for
the first time in my life which
guys it sounds crazy coming from me and
at the time guys i was when i met her
all right i was 37 years old let me tell
you something guys when you're 37 years
old and she was 30 and she had been
cheated on the whole [__] deal
you know and i had gone through my
[__] mess and it's so weird when you
when you speak to a girl when she's 21
like the guy she wants i want tall dark
he has to have a boat and then when
they're 30 check her out again
you know she's been cheated on the guy
[__] her cousin at the wedding you
know
you know
and then when you bump into them when
they're 40 they start talking about
teeth
and a job and [__]
a okay car the same girl that told you
her husband had to have a lamborghini
and all this [__] now says i'll take a
ford prius i don't give a [__] you know
i just want a guy that has a job and
treats me well
and i started thinking about that i was
37 years old
guys i had no job i had no car i had
nothing going for me i had been doing
comedy for
nine years
i was a regular at the store i had zero
bank account i had four pair of pants
four shirts four sweaters a hooded
sweatshirt no underwear you know i'm not
lying to you guys i mean i had nothing
and
i think uh the first time i was like wow
we're on to something here
was when i went to new york the story i
told on
on uh sickler that i was going to new
york and she hunted me down
and there was a party at ralphy's
and she came over
and we were just [__] hanging out
whatever it's like ralphie celine god
rest her soul
ricky cruz he'll be here next week
uh sean rouse scott resisto jody ferg i
mean it was a we used to have these
great little parties in the building
and i left the comedy store one night
and i didn't see my ex-wife she was
wrapping up she's my girlfriend at the
time
we were dating i don't know what the
[__] we were doing
and uh
she showed up at ralphie mae's house and
she's like hey
you know i came by to say goodbye i know
you're going to new york today and i was
pretty embarrassed
like that she was there i was i think i
was i had done like a couple lines and
that's why i didn't want her around
because at that time whenever i did coke
i would disappear i would i wouldn't
want to see it me high
so i was coming down that night and we
talked to her a little while on the
couch and then we just started talking
outside
and it was like you hear the michael
jackson song remember the time
when we fell in love you know i have
always loved that song
you know i'm a stupid romantic at time
that's a great [__] jam and
he says when we used to talk all night
on the phone when you meet somebody and
you fall in love
you could talk to them all night on the
[__] phone and but
i didn't even have a phone i didn't even
have a cell phone to talk to all night
we were out in the stoop just talking
all [__] night
about life and what i wanted from this
show i was going to do in new york and
i'll never forget she's like all right
you got to start getting ready and i go
all right
and i turned around and she goes are you
okay do you have enough money to go i
have like four cigarettes
maybe three joints and maybe seven
dollars something like that guys i know
can you imagine getting on a plane with
seven dollars
and three cigarettes in those days i
used to get on planes
when the plane would land for a
collecting flight i would [__] go
behind the counter at the airport and
steal a pack of cigarettes
that's how [__] crazy i was guys i
just want you to know that that there
was no nothing
and that night i go i gotta go take a
shower she goes do you want to ride to
the airport again i didn't want to you
know for somebody to give you a ride to
the airport in those days it's lax it's
six in the morning
it sucks and i i was like embarrassed
and she goes i'll give you a ride to the
airport and then she goes how much money
do you have and i was like i got nothing
i got like seven dollars and she had
like forty dollars that she made
waitressing and she goes don't worry
about it i'm gonna go home and sleep all
day i got change at the house
and i work again tonight i'll get money
to buy groceries and [__] we were both
[__] poor that's the first time in my
life i ever took money from a woman like
i it's not my
it was never something that was in my
world you know
i took money from [__] my aunt when
my mother died so ryder you know i took
money from her but she was a woman and i
was a kid that was a different story
after i turned 18 i didn't make it a
hobby to have a woman support me
no
these guys i thought that was cool that
was never in my boat i don't know if i'm
a control freak i don't know what it is
i just don't want a woman supporting me
i could see if if you're in a bump if
you're if you already been with a woman
for 10 years and you break an ankle and
you need some help for six weeks but for
me to live off a woman it wasn't gonna
happen
no matter what situation i was in and
this girl gave me like the last forty
dollars and i was like
what the [__] am i gonna do i didn't
want to take it because i knew if i took
it
i'd be indebted to her
but it was the first time that somebody
wanted to help me from their heart so i
took the [__] money
and i mean i came to new york and the
whole time i thought of her i had to
come to new york to do a show uh a
one-man show at the hbo workspace
i ate a bag of dicks i wasn't going i
wasn't even prepared
but i remember coming back and like just
being blown away and then i tried to
hide from her for a while
like i went like an extended road trip
to texas for like three weeks and that's
when i would go to houston and just do
the whole month in texas
and i remember coming back and she was
like i want to pick you up at the
airport and i'm like no
because i look like a [__] train hit
me you know if i when i went to texas
it meant that i was going down to the
snow coke that's it and do comedy you
know
houston was the best place for me to do
it
and i [__] uh came back from that
trip and i'll never forget you picked me
up at the airport
and it was toys like september and
i go where are we going and she goes
let's go back to my house and we went to
her house and we ate and
i gave her some money that i owed her
you know i gave her even though she
didn't ask for it and i'll never forget
her going listen joey you've been gone
for a while
i could use help with the rent you know
um
if you'd like you could stay here and i
was like that'd be very nice here
at the time i was just crashing at
anybody's house i was crashing at
ralphie's couch
or john wesley i was crashing in like
three different places
and i'll never forget i go that's great
and she goes once you eat something
take a shower get some rest and when
we're finished
we'll go down there and pick up your
clothes and i go
this is everything i got it was an army
bag
and i go this is everything i got this
is as good as it gets in my life
and she was [__] blown the [__] away
and uh as embarrassing as that was you
know
usually
when you meet a girl you know we lie to
them
we tell them we're more important than
what we are and
or we lie about our salaries or whatever
you know with her i never had a lie
she knew i was a bum
i mean
she knew i was a bum but she saw
something i
i recently asked her i don't know a
couple years ago when she goes i used to
watch you in the original room on sunday
nights joey and i thought that
i thought that you were just not getting
the brakes that you deserved or
something you know
but it was just great to have uh like i
i just had a bad taste in my mouth from
women you know all those [__] years
and it's
i think about my first marriage a lot
guys and i want to share this with you
because
after 30 years ago i could just say you
know man
there's a lot of people who make hasty
decisions in their life when we're young
i was one of them
i got married over a religious [__]
i got married because i didn't want
a girl to have an abortion
was i in love with it i don't [__]
know but i let my religious beliefs
wrote me into a marriage that
i didn't want to be at number one number
two i wasn't ready for
you know and i got to be honest with you
guys i don't think a lot of you guys are
ready for these marriages
and i think that people rush into
marriage today i look at all these young
kids like when i lived in l.a i got
invited to one wedding a year and it was
somebody here you know when you just put
200 in the card and go i'm not [__]
taking a six-hour flight for a [__]
wedding but now that i'm here
i'm getting invited to a bunch of
weddings and i'm looking at these people
i'm not talking about you mike i'm
talking about like uh
i have a friend that i got an invite for
their kids and i'm looking at them
they're 23.
they're 23. you know and
i could see that where they get married
you know i could see the type of kid she
is
the demands she's already making and i
think sometimes women [__] uh
they don't think right about who they're
gonna marry they're so concerned with
the [__] wedding
they get so blindsided by the [__]
smoke that they don't see the fire and
trust me guys
i was blindsided by a wedding and i
don't forget being on that plane with
her right after the wedding
and going what the [__] that i just did
it was the worst
case of buyer's remorse in the [__]
world man
listen and
dog i'm no genius but i guarantee a lot
of people get married and three days
later to get buyer's remorse because
whatever
you know it's like i i have a girl i
went to school with and
her daughter contacted me like three
years ago me and this girl didn't talk
for like 25 [__] years
over some stupid [__] and the daughter
called me she's like i'm her daughter
and and i'm like oh my god the daughter
was so [__] goofy and i went online i
looked at the daughter and her husband
oh my god
i can't believe that my friend is from
north bergen because if my daughter
would have showed up with that guy
i would have beat the [__] out of that
guy and then told my daughter you're
done you gotta go you gotta pick your
higher levels this guy he was like a tap
dancer
which right away is not bueno in my book
and he's he looks like a tap dance link
and he's got the smile
and they posted pictures the other day
this is the best way to get have
children with your best friend from
college and both husbands had matching
hood things where you hold the babies
listen i'd rather stick a [__] knife
in my eye
i really do
the first time you see me next to
another 50 year old with matching baby
holsters and they have like actually say
something just stop talking to me just
stop like joey you [__] you you
[__] disappointed us to the highest
degree of life how can you have a
matching baby carrier with some other
half a [__] it looked terrible but anyway
not to dwell on that like i see
these young girls that they don't even
know they picked these half of [__]
and they did i just want to get married
with my my bestie what the [__] are you
talking about i wouldn't marry that guy
if he was the last guy on [__] earth
with his little [__] car shoes you
know those little black and white shoes
like elvis costello [__] that can knock
it off yeah knock it the [__] off guys
oh my god
so what you know like i made a [__]
huge mistake when i got married
obviously she made a huge mistake
when she got married to me
but this marriage i mean i took with
everything that i
i listen i did not want to get married
in fact i was content with dying [__]
alone i listened guys i had had
i had had it and not that i had been
just the last thing with my with
with my daughter jackie and my ex-wife
and how it went
if you knew anything about it i was
ready to give up on [__] love i had
no right
falling in love i was old for nine
i maybe had three [__] good
girlfriends and then uh
but i gotta tell you what happened from
that interview
tuesday night i was sitting here
watching my business
and i got a call from my old girlfriend
the one i dated before terry there was
one chick i had like a little affair
with in between there
and then there was a chick i dated for
five years maybe i dated her from
95 to yeah like 99 like that
and that was a weird relationship we
were i'm more fool we were like tony
soprano in the chickie choke i forget
what her name was
me and her
we loved each other there was a lot of
passion
so out of nowhere this chick hits me up
and she goes hey man i listen to your
ryan cycle podcast today
now we're tight here and i are [__]
super tight i talked to i'm her kid's
godfather you know
but she was like do you have a minute to
jump on a call and i'm like not really
my wife is sitting next to me i mean
we're watching something i go can i call
you a little one i called her back
and we ended up talking on the phone to
like one in the morning about where our
relationship went wrong
and how she felt years later
she felt that i didn't give her a chance
at the end
she goes we were having a lot of
problems but you didn't want to give me
a chance and i go listen
i'm the type of guy man but i give
everything a chance but there was
nothing in the world i wanted at that
time more
was to be accepted as a stand-up comic
and you were getting in my way
and i don't know what day this week it
all made sense because
i think one day this week rogan and
uh infamous
the kid i forget what his name is crazy
man from new york city
uh he was schultz schultz was on his
podcast
and he was telling schultz said joey
diaz was
[__] destroying people in the parking
lot
but then he could he would get up on
stage and suck a bag of dicks he was
funny naturally
but he didn't know how to transform it
and i always tell people that i was
going for something and a lot of you
guys are going for things
and uh
this girl was putting a lot of weight on
my life
i loved her very much and
i cared for her very much but at the
same time i wasn't looking to get
married i wasn't looking to have [__]
kids i wasn't looking to go to dinner
with your [__] parents
like i wasn't looking to go to a wedding
because your sister's getting you know
once you take a relationship to meet
your parents it only goes
uphill the next step is you know nobody
wants to meet your [__] parents
you know if a chick's a dirty hoe and
she brings 80 guys over
a month
she you know she doesn't want to [__]
she doesn't want to [__] uh
bring another guy home whatever the [__]
i'm trying to get to so
you know we just talked about what went
wrong
in the relationship and i'll tell you
something at 60 years old now man
it's so great to be able to look into
your life and see where you made these
[__]
huge mistakes i loved i loved my
ex-girlfriend before terry loved her
loved her
but she took up too much my energy and
that energy was taken away from my
standup
and as soon as we broke up
i launched as a stand-up comic i mean i
didn't become
[__] george carlin
but i made these strides like sometimes
you're cutting the plateau
right after that relationship broke i
got to a different level and stand up
because i had lost
all that
you spend so much energy thinking about
somebody
your future that you lose sight of
what's in [__] in front of you
so
i mean this week after watching the
the sickler podcast well i didn't watch
it people
thinking about what i said those words
and then having that conversation
with my ex-girlfriend [__] just
really
helped me to look into where i made
mistakes as a young man
with relationships and you know what
listen
i i always feel guilty about my 10 years
in boulder being single or it was like
five years in boulder and then i was
really
always with this girl from florida since
95 to 99 so in reality i was only single
for like five [__] years from 90 to
95 and i was involved in some
you know
i was involved with some great girls
from time to time i was involved with
girls that were crazy and i got to be
honest i was involved with girls that
[__] were looking for the same thing
i was looking for
which is [__] scary like they were in
the same boat as me
i think of a relationship i was having
in boulder where i would see her once a
week she was involved in a [__]
four or five-year relationship
and on sunday night she would come over
and go i broke up with him
let's go take row hypnos
and we go to a warehouse behind the
strip club the strip club was called the
bus stop
and up there there were these like uh
you know those aluminum garages you know
those little storage facilities there
was a guy who lived in a storage
facility it was like a thousand degrees
he'd always open the garage sweating
profusely and [__] there's 95.
and then we used to go in and buy ruby
roofies
and go out to
this uh
margarita place in boulder [__]
tremendous you had a three margarita
limit
and we
only allowed three for person
three margaritas and they asked you to
leave
and [__] uh
our job was to dose each other
without the other guy knowing
[__] brilliant [__]
within three drinks and then we go
somewhere and snork coke and [__]
and black out i mean we'd black out and
wake up on monday and she'd go i'm late
for work see you next sunday and then
tuesday i go to the restaurant and she'd
be there swap and spit with her
boyfriend and she'd wave and the
boyfriend would wave and then sunday
like a week later i'd see her again she
go we're broken up and she'd do it again
she'd go back with a monday morning i
felt like a [__]
horrible person but
it wasn't me
it was her it wasn't like i wasn't
cheating on anybody i was just [__]
trying to be a young guy you know
i'm just trying to snort coke but i had
it was horrible and looking back at it
like it's a lifestyle that you think you
like like all these guys like all i need
is a piece of ass once a month and i'm
good well i was getting a piece of ass
once a month and i gotta tell you
something
didn't [__] feel good
just didn't [__] feel good at all man
but anyway that's what i wanted to touch
base on this beautiful [__]
monday
it's a great it's going to be a great
month i'm having a great summer so far
my life is right where i want to be it
uh i was talking to lee and i'm like lee
listen
i don't give a [__] about money i don't
give a [__] about none of this [__] you
know
when i was living in l.a with those
[__]
dumpsters that [__] you know
they made you feel desperate like they
always made you feel like you were
missing out if you weren't working and
now i'm feeling great that i'm just
[__] at home i don't care about the
money
i'm feeling better i'm looking better
i'm acting better my stand-up is getting
a little better i'm excited you know the
thing that i i was guys honest to god
i was a little i was going to pull back
on the residency
and look into like uh
the theater in red bank
i was also going to look at before i
started this new york residency
i was also going to look at a residency
maybe at oceans
maybe at the borgata okay that'd be
close to the home
i thought the numbers were going to go
up this winter and i didn't really want
to go into the city and have to wear a
mask i'm not doing a show where
you guys are wearing a mask
i'd rather cancel the [__] show
but now after the shows are sold out i
can tell you that these shows are
sponsored by [__] laughing gas
you know the first show is me and ari
and the second show is me
kim tavares uh kim condom and sarah
weincheck they they work for the
uh laughing gas so they'll be coming in
october 8th but what i wanted to tell
you guys was i really wanted to [__]
switch the residency to new jersey just
because i was scared of mandates and
[__]
and i read something
they sent me like this thing like a week
before and it said what do you like joey
d is this joey d is that
there was something about joey diaz on
broadway
that just
it just made me think of [__] uh
jackie gleason
it made me think of anybody who ever did
anything special in new york i always
wanted to do something special in new
york
i remember so much of new york as a
child how it [__]
made me feel when i walked to times
square i used to walk to times square
with my godfather with my mom from 88th
street and i i still remember how i felt
as a kid just walking down broadway
passing the lincoln center
and all that [__] it really makes me
proud man i got a month and i'm gonna
try to do the best shows i can
i'm looking into a dj you know i'm
looking into some [__] two girls
dancing like uh
like the [__] uh what's my group with
slash and
that group that he had velvet revolver
that one song he's got girls dancing in
the bubble like dressed nice in a cage
i'm gonna try to get two of those girls
to dress in the cage
you know i just want to do something
different guys so it's uh
five dates
like i said they're forty dollar tickets
do not pay a [__] dime more than
forty dollars it's ten dollars for the
service fee i did this for you guys
to you know listen everybody's raping
the american public did you see that ad
on friday that plane tickets are still
going to go up more listen they're
trying to [__] rape us
you're already starting to see pieces of
this
i'm starting to see it already two weeks
ago i had a in uh point pleasant guys
point pleasant in july it's like the
hottest place on earth
everybody's down there they either take
day trips from northern new jersey or
new york
my neighbors around the corner went to
jenkins there was nobody there at 10
o'clock at night guys
you know we're already starting to see
this i just didn't want to
be a problem i wanted to be a solution
and i want to have a good time with you
guys so like i said do not pay over
fifty dollars for those tickets i love
you [__] with all my heart
uh you're gonna hear some sponsors you
had you heard better help before
and that's it and that's that i want to
thank you guys for watching on a monday
morning it's a new month [__] and
i'll see you little bastards wednesday
tip top magoo [__] stay black
all right i want to thank you [__]
savages for listening on a beautiful
monday morning the joint is brought to
you by better help what's better help
online therapy
that works how do i know because they
helped uncle joey listen your brain
health affects how you experience life
investing time and energy and mental
health is crucial especially what we've
gone through over the last two years i
know you're eating right you're staying
in you're not jumping up and down a
party
but better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient most importantly
affordable i was struggling for a few
months i contacted dana i had better
help i started seeing it four times a
month now i'm down at two times a month
and as you guys can see my life has
changed i'm uh i'm comfortable with who
i am and i'm comfortable in my skin
again so do me a favor
you could choose to see somebody and not
see anybody on camera it's up to you
it's more affordable than in person
therapy and you could be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours that's
better help joint listeners i'm going to
get you 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz the joint is brought to you by one
of my personal favorites
liquid iv listen the summer months it's
[__] hot and you need to be proactive
about keeping your bodies fueled and
hydrated making a hydration a priority
is going to help you feel healthier in
your everyday lives one stick
of liquid iv in 16 ounces of water
hydrates you two times faster than water
alone liquid iv is tremendous i love it
they even have a kombucha now they have
a hydration they have an immune system
but they also have 10 flavors pina
coladas tremendous tropical punch
concord grape the cherries great listen
go with liquid iv first thing in the
morning before a workout or when you
feel run down from a long night of
getting your whistle twisted you know
what i'm saying the single use package
makes it easy for you to stay hydrated
while you're traveling it contains five
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c
that's three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks so grab your
liquid iv in bulk at costco you can do
that but you're not gonna get no [__]
savings if you go through joey and
liquidity.com and pressing joey at
checkout i'm gonna get you 15 this
shit's expensive it's tremendous and it
works but uncle joey's here to save you
some money so put in code joey and i'm
getting your fifteen percent off head go
get your whistle bent i love you
[__] have a great week stay
black
and i'll talk to you guys wednesday
morning tiptopa goon
you